Speaker 1: I have some amazing video from radical
Republican Congresswoman Lauren Boebert recent
debate. As some of you may know, there is a 2022
midterm election just around the corner now about
seven weeks away. And some of the main debates are
starting. We are following very closely Will John
Fetterman and Mehmet Oz debate. Will Herschel
Walker finally agree to debate? Raphael Warnock
And we are following all of these. Lauren Boebert
participated in a debate against her opponent,
Adam Frisch, and she seemed to glitch very, very
badly. I don't know how many of you remember when
Marco Rubio, during a Republican primary debate
in 2016, repeated the same answer multiple times,
almost like a glitchy robot? I don't know how
many of you remember Kelly Loeffler with her
radical liberal. Raphael Warnock repeated it
repeated line during her debates with Raphael
Warnock. Lauren Boebert answering close to
a dozen questions by talking about Nancy
Pelosi and her con game. It is bizarre. The
boebert bot glitching badly. Check this out.
Speaker 3: Candidate boebert you
have 3 minutes for that. Nancy
pelosi is running a con game in washington, d.c..
Speaker 1: By the way, nancy pelosi is not lauren
boebert opponent. In case in case you thought,
maybe that's why she kept talking about Pelosi.
Speaker 3: Nancy's con game works like
this. Fire. Nancy Pelosi. Nancy Pelosi's.
Speaker 4: I'm Adam Fresh. I'm not Nancy
Pelosi. I'm Adam. Freshman Nancy Pelosi.
Speaker 3: Nancy Pelosi plays with Pelosi's con
game. The Pelosi pushes this, but she will put a
2000 page bill on our desks at midnight. Nancy
Pelosi's con game playing Nancy's con game to do
it, yeah. DC To play Nancy Pelosi's con game. I It
makes me terribly sad when Nancy Pelosi uses the
same image, more inflation, more borrowing from
China, and Pelosi knows it. Pelosi's con games.
This was a blank check and.
Speaker 4: Okay.
I'm Adam first. I'm not Nancy Pelosi.
Speaker 3: There was no interest. And
Nancy Pelosi is running a con
game under pelosi. Democrats are
told the Pelosi con game in aspen and
just. Like Pelosi Budget Committee and
Nancy Pelosi will not. It's not time to help Nancy
Pelosi. It is time to fire Nancy
Pelosi. This election say no to
liberal extremists and their army of IRS agents.
Speaker 4: I'm Adam Fresh. I'm not Nancy Pelosi.
I'm Adam Fresh. I'm not Nancy Pelosi.
Speaker 1: Look,
they have quite literally nothing to offer.
There is nothing to offer there. And if you
live in Lauren Boebert district in Colorado, it's
a very red district. I understand that in Boebert.
Oh, no, actually, this may be a district
that was redrawn. So in any case,
the previously Boebert district was was a very
red district. Fine. You don't like Nancy Pelosi,
but don't you as a Republican in her district?
Boebert district. Still want to hear some vision
of what Boebert will do, even if it's things that
I don't agree with. Don't their own voters want to
hear? Here are the types of regulations I'm going
to try to get cut. Here's how I would change the
tax code. Here's here are the types of projects I
would support in order to bring dollars into this
district. Like, it seems weird that even the
voters in Colorado are so concerned with Nancy
Pelosi in this way that this would be an effective
campaign strategy. But the saddest thing about it
is that this stuff can probably work okay in these
highly weaponized electorates, when you have such
a highly weaponized constituency as Lauren Boebert
does, where they don't even really understand the
types of things Lauren Boebert could be advocating
for for them. They have become propagandized to
the point where her own voters believe the role of
someone like Boebert, whoever is their member of
Congress, is to do things like fight the Pelosi
con job. We have such a lack of education and
understanding of what these elected officials
can even do for us. That there was a time where
the way that these debates would go would be
it would be a focus on the district. And. Sure,
yeah. I mean, listen, Congress has a investigative
role when it comes to whether to bring articles
of impeachment. And Congress has an oversight
role. Of course, they choose the speaker of the
House. Yes, but there was a time when what
voters wanted to hear was their candidate's
understanding of their district, not what's
going on in Nancy Pelosi's San Francisco or
in Washington, D.C. understand what's going on in
our district. Hey, you know what? In our district,
we have a dozen bridges that are rated low,
whatever, high risk of possible failure.
Here are the three ways in which I'm going to take
care of those bridges in our district so that all
of your commutes to work are safer so that we
don't risk huge traffic interruptions when these
and loss of life. We prevent loss of life when you
and your kids are driving over. This is just an
example. But there was a time where that was the
approach and the candidates would debate about,
well, I would like to better our infrastructure
this way versus the other candidate wants to
better our infrastructure that way. I'm talking
30 years ago at least. Okay. But that's the way
it used to be. It's now, oh, Nancy Pelosi's con
job. And this is something they just they've tried
before with this stuff. It fortunately failed for
Kelly Loeffler. But remember when Kelly Loeffler
pulled this or tried to pull it against Raphael
Warnock during that special election in 2021?
Speaker 3: The Democrats want to fundamentally
change America, and the agent of change is my
opponent. Radical, liberal. Raphael Warnock. My
opponent radical liberal. Raphael Warnock. Radical
Liberal. Raphael Warnock. Radical Liberal
Raphael Warnock. Radical Liberal Raphael
Warnock. Radical Liberal Raphael Warnock Radical
Liberal Rafael Warnock. Right is a socialist and
radical liberal. Raphael Warnock Radical
Liberal. Raphael Warnock Radical Liberal.
Raphael Warnock Radical Liberal of Raphael
Warnock Radical Liberal Raphael Warnock.
Speaker 1: Anyway, it goes on from there. Now,
fortunately, in that special election in Georgia,
it didn't work. And there were some
special dynamics, including, quite frankly,
that Trump and people around him were saying it
was all rigged anyway in Georgia in November.
And that probably dissuaded a lot of Republicans
from even going out to vote on January 5th in that
special election. Because, listen, even their
Dear Orange leader told them, it's all rigged.
Your vote essentially doesn't matter. So a lot
of special things went on there. And so it didn't
work for Leffler. But this is not a new thing, and
it has succeeded for them to some degree because
their constituents accept it. They have come
to embrace a complete lack of policy discussion
in exchange for accepting things like, Well,
Warnock's a socialist and Nancy Pelosi's running a
country. Job. Let's see how it works out for them.
In November next week, on 919 September 19, we
will be doing our next one day membership special
folding in many new members into the ranks of
membership. I hope if you've been thinking I would
get a membership, but it's got to be a good deal.
Get on my newsletter at David Pakman dot com. And
then next Monday, 919, you'll get an email from us
bright and early in the morning telling you how to
take advantage of this great membership discount.